hello everybody
microtransactions they are the big topic
on everybody's mind when it comes to
video games nowadays because like it or
not there in most video games so this is
something that a lot of people were
asking for in the tips video that I put
up over the weekend and so I thought I
want you guys to be informed consumers
so we're just gonna talk about what
exactly Barkov eyes microtransactions
are and what you can expect when you
play the game so here we are in the game
this is just in the open world if you
hit the start button here playing on the
ps4 there is a store page we're gonna go
into the store page and this is where
you're gonna be spending all of your
money you see here on the Left they
offer the season pass they also offer it
again over here on the right then you
can buy weapons vehicles clothing and
silver bars so the silver bars are the
premium currency if I try and buy them
right now actually they're not for sale
so initially I wasn't sure how much they
cost but I found a GameSpot sorry came
stop see even we do it
a Gamestop listing that was a selling
premium silver for 20 bucks and you got
2000 silver plus a bonus for hundred I
the 400 is basically like because they
say it's a bonus I believe that to
believe that doesn't apply to like the
base price so it's probably a simple
like 1 to 1 of 100 silver gets you a
dollar which at the very least is simple
and easy to understand unlike other
currencies so let's look at what you can
get with some of these prestige weapons
ok here we are so we got a a special
shovel special sniper rifle special
grenade launcher basically these are all
these same weapons in the game but they
have cool skins on them as you can see
here they're offered at let's see we got
200 silver sets $2 $4 $5 $5 $4 and it
kind of goes from there there's all
sorts of stuff they're selling for each
category that's about it though it's
really just skins it's basically the
same weapons
that are offered in the regular game as
we'll see in a moment same with vehicles
the vehicles are just kind of skin
versions of vehicles you can normally
find I mean they admittedly are very
nice skins but again you're paying two
dollars four dollars you know five
dollars seems like fives maybe them max
with this kind of stuff so it doesn't go
above five dollars the clothing let's
check out here have some pretty cool
stuff as well
they're all starting at like yeah five
three four this stuff is cool but also
only really useful in the arcade mode
because the games in first person so if
you're playing by yourself or you're not
playing co-op you don't really see any
of this so it not really much of a
reason to get any of this stuff that's
cool as some of it does look alright so
that it's pretty much everything in the
store here now there is also the in-game
stores as well where you buy your normal
stuff through money and we're gonna talk
to this guy to kind of see how that
looks as you can see here it's very
similar menu there's no add for the
season pass which is good nice but they
do still offer you to buy silver bars
which a little annoying but it's easy
enough to ignore thankfully so in
weapons here let's go into them as you
can see they feature all those nice
premium weapons and here they offer the
ability to buy them with actual in-game
money that is about three thousand six
hundred dollars which is a decent amount
of in-game money to spend so they do
cost a little bit but the thing is I
don't know why you'd want to get it over
just the basic shovel because it doesn't
have any better stats it's just a visual
difference and you actually don't even
need to buy the shoulder you just find
one in the world and the same goes with
a lot of the weapons here so you know we
got all of these guns and they all cost
about actually the same as no ammo like
Far Cry game so he can think about three
and four the way those economies worked
they were all the same so there was
never it doesn't feel like they've
compromised the
the price of the normal in-game currency
to incentivize the micro transactions
like I have never felt any desire at all
to spend money even though I can't right
now
but I've never I've never even felt that
poll like it just feels like I'm playing
a normal Far Cry game without any micro
transactions in it but then you know if
we go out the bottom they still do offer
these versions as well but again you can
buy them with with real world where with
actual like in-game money so if you
really want them you can easily get them
and in fact I did get a couple will go
here to the rifle and I bought this
rifle here which is a color version of
this one also like these have skins as
well so like I go to this here you can
get like cool skins and get a prestige
skin as well which also will cost
in-game bar money or yeah or sorry it'll
cost in-game money or bar money but
again you can just pay the in-game money
and it's fine like I have enough to buy
it so yeah that's basically everything
that the microtransactions have to offer
and honestly it is pretty good in the
sense that if you were somebody who does
not like microtransactions didn't want
them to be invasive these are so not in
your way that like I just I kind of
forgot they were in the game you know
I've been playing for 20 hours and I've
barely even thought about the
microtransactions they have not been in
my way at all on the other hand I do
kind of feel a little bad if anyone does
end up buying these microtransactions
because you can get them in the game you
can get them in the game really easily
in fact it's not that hard to make money
in this game so I honestly think it's
they're not even I don't think they even
need to be in the game like I don't
think anyone should buy these personally
but if you do buy them I mean you know
whatever that's that's your decision I'm
not gonna judge you for that anyway that
is everything that Far Cry 5 has to
offer when it comes to microtransactions
seems seems fine I I don't think this is
vital rated I would say it is pretty
okay it's not intrusive it's not
invasive what they have to offer is a
little lame in my opinion but if you
want to get it
go ahead and thanks for watching guys
and if you want to see us do more if you
like this and you like being informed
about microtransactions which a lot of
people on the internet seem to do and
you want us to try and do this with more
games please let me know and have a
great day
[Music]